[Musique]
allo jessica jones
tu es une tricheuse
[Musique]
on t'a offert tous les avantages
possibles
tu as eu droit à l'erreur encore et
encore
tu ne sais pas de contrôle et je les ai
vus tu n'as pas pu monstre discipline
uniquement la force brute
alors qu'est ce que tu veux je veux te
voir morte
grégory salinger est plus malin que toi
et moi réuni s'invite en retz oui je
sais qui vous êtes
c'est loin d'être un secret donc vous
savez je peux vous défoncer la tronche
j'ai du mal à survivre si salinger caf
et a alors points sont là j'ai pas
besoin de ton aide et a pas besoin de la
mienne
il a été arrêté de façon arbitraire
quand on se frotte de trop près à des
personnes violentes les gens autour de
nous
[Musique]
tout le monde a une histoire avec un
début un milieu et une fin où m'attend
au boulot quel boulot super
cambrioleuses mais ça va j'ai suivi ta
méthode
maintenant je vais suivre vienne qu'à la
fin de cette affaire j'ai encore un peu
de respect pour votre respect envers moi
est vraiment le cadet de mes soucis
jessica jones tu pensais sauver le monde
tous les décevoir
ce que tu as fait parce que tu n'es pas
et tu ne seras jamais
[Musique]
on reste une héroïne si les gens pensent
le contraire
ce que les gens pensent je m'en
contrefous